here are some celebrities who you
probably didn't even realize were
related through marriage Jake
Gyllenhaal's brother-in-law is Peter
Skarsgard Jak sister Maggie Gyllenhaal
is married to Peter the two of them got
married in 2009 and they share a
16-year-old daughter named Ramona this
one I love Nicole and Sophia Richie
gained a sister-in-law in Cameron Diaz
so Cameron married Good Charlotte member
Benji Madden in 2015 while Nicole
Married Benji's twin brother Joel Madden
in 2010
Ashley Simpson's mother-in-law is
legendary singer Diana Ross Ashley is
married to Diana's son actor and
musician Evan Ross and technically that
also means that Ashley's sister-in-law
is blackish star Tracy Alice Ross share
with me all your thoughts on this in the
comments below